hey everybody Jeff Raven and add
McLaughlin here from wacky gamer we're
here at the 2010 comic-con we're going
to be posting a bunch of footage next
week on wacky gamer comedy make sure to
subscribe but for now check out this
awesome footage from the Halo Reach
session Bungie announced a bunch of
different configurations for their
multiplayer modes I think people are
really gonna dig them here's some
awesome footage and we thought you know
what what if you get to play from the
Covenant perspective so if you look in
the lower left-hand corner you'll see I
have a new armor ability hologram
I'm gonna show you guys something tool
one minute remains
so we do have unique assassinations for
the sword now yeah that's pretty sweet
and we're going to reveal one more new
thing its brand new vehicle you guys
have never seen before all this run over
here real quick the forklift
hold on hold on quiet quiet
if you ever wanted to know what's beyond
the canyon here's some awesome footage
of the rest of Ford's world
so what is beyond the canyon
the majority of the men
Bunji also announced a new Xbox design
for Halo so if you feel like spending an
extra two hundred and fifty dollars on a
piece of equipment you already own go to
town it's actually gonna be three
hundred dollars you could just go buy a
360 and spray-painted silver
keep your eyes peeled we'll have some
exclusive footage of the new features
they add it to forge the in-game editor
including some maps they made at Bungie
specifically with Forge check it out
they look super Swede